welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you now on the
upside down to the spoiler free side of
YouTube as voted by you throughout this
video we're gonna be breaking down
everything we know about the upcoming
season of stranger things this we'll be
covering the potential release date
casting news story details and our fan
theories on what could be happening in
the show there may be some spoilers here
so if you don't want anything about the
season potentially ruined then I
recommend that you go through the
doorway and check out of the video now
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown of
stranger things season 4 stranger things
season three ended on a massive
cliffhanger with lots of things up in
the air firstly we were unsure about Jim
hoppers fate and secondly we didn't have
a clue whether the group would ever see
each other again after the buyers moved
away with 11 theories were further
fueled for the former due to the fact
that we never actually saw hopper die
after the machine that opened the
doorway to the upside down exploded
hoppers body was nowhere to be seen
and thus the internet went wild though
those around it were disintegrating
explosion when re watching the Machine
go into meltdown we could clearly see
that he wasn't on the walkway
he also eyed up the doorway before all
went to hell and with the post-credits
scene teasing an American that was
locked up everything pointed to the
character being alive this was confirmed
in February 2020 with the arrival of a
full teaser trailer for the season that
showed the character was indeed alive
and well in Russia we know this because
of the musical cues and also the title
of the trailer itself was From Russia
With Love not long after this the duffer
brothers released a statement that said
the following we are excited to
officially confirm that production and
stranger things for is now underway and
even more excited to announce the return
of hopper although it's not all good
news for our American he is in prison
far from home in the snowy wastin of
camp chapter here he will face dangers
both human and other meanwhile back in
the States and new horror is beginning
to surface something long buried
something that connects everything
season four is shaping up to be the
biggest and most frightening season yet
and we cannot wait for everyone to see
more in the meantime pray for the
American so whilst the word theories
that Brenner could indeed be the one in
the cell we now know for definite that
Hopper was the American that the
Russians were referring to as for the
big bad anyone who thinks that the mind
flayer is dead is clearly in for a big
surprise the monster that we saw
destroyed in season three is actually a
puppet of the mine fire and not the mine
player itself the only reason that the
creature died at the end was because the
connection between the real world and
the upside down was cut off and thus the
mine player was enabled to control its
conduit any further though the mine fire
is trapped in the upside down currently
we do know that Russia are still trying
to open poles to the plane and therefore
I doubt the villain will be down for
very long so the antagonist will be back
and back with a vengeance we also know
that the Russians have managed to
capture a demagogue in as we see from
the season 4 trailer the base is still
standing so it looks like they've been
successful in their experiments of the
upside down they will likely continue
these and who knows we may even get
another monster in the season in
addition to this the teaser trailer that
was released before the aforementioned
one was crowned with Easter eggs that I
think will make a big appearance in the
first episode of the new season firstly
to the right of the logo you can see a
sign for Hawkins which shows that the
upside down is slowly morphing into the
area even more this could explain how
hopper was able to survive down there
for so long as if the area is changing
then the atmosphere will go along with
it in addition to this just to the left
behind the sign we can also make out a
small cabin with a candle beside it this
is likely the shelter where the
character lived during his time in the
area and the fact that he has a home
shows that he was down there for a long
time it's very Yoda like an Empire
Strikes Back was a massive movie in the
80s and well still is and I think this
little Easter egg is a nostalgic nod to
that film and Dagobah on top of all this
we also have a good indicator when the
fourth season will be releasing if you
look to the left-hand side of the sign
you will see a clock which is set to
12:30 in the finale those lip service
paid to the characters reuniting a
Christmas and this does seem to fit in
line with that
or rather around that
though we don't know the exact release
day of the show just yet the 12:30 to me
means that they're youth of December
this is a big time for Netflix as many
people are off over the holidays and the
streaming giant will likely launch it at
a time where they'll get large audience
numbers I can't see any other reason why
they would place the clock here like
this
so it does make a lot of sense in the
past the show has always released on
special holidays such as Halloween and
the fourth of July so this being
sandwiched between Christmas and New
Year would line up with that schedule
along with Christmas the characters in
the finale did mention Thanksgiving but
I can't see this being more of a journey
for Mike who will go and see 11 and the
buyers I think that after this the
buyers and 11 will return to Hawkins for
Christmas and this will be where most of
the season is set Hawkins is just the
best place to set the show for me I
think it makes the most sense of what we
know so far so yes Christmas seems like
the best bet for the setting of season 4
during an interview with in Poland Cora
bono who stars as Karen wheelers stated
that season four started shooting in
October last year the show this far has
had a roughly 15 month production
schedule with the third season starting
in April two thousand 18 before
launching in July the following year the
30th of December does line up with their
schedules and regular release times so
it makes a ton of sense for the season
to drop then of course let me know your
theories below but I can't really come
up with any other thing that the clock
could be in addition to this we do know
that the first episode of season four
will be called the Hellfire Club the
Hellfire Club has been a name throughout
history that's been repurposed for
several exclusive groups
it's appeared in tons of comic books TV
shows and a lot more over the years but
it originates all the way back in
Britain during the 18th century the name
was used to refer to the order of Friars
back then but now it takes on a
completely different meaning its most
famous use at the moment is in the x-men
franchise most notably the Dark Phoenix
saga and which the club attempted to get
Jean Grey to join them eleven is of
course blessed with telekinetic powers
similar to Jean and both characters can
move things with their mind Jean got
increasingly more powerful throughout
the Dark Phoenix saga whereas when we
last saw 11 she was actually struggling
to use her abilities could it be that
the Hellfire Club
eleven that they can help to get her
powers back well I'm actually starting
to think so now it could be possible
that this name could also mean a number
of things from Russians to the group
themselves but that is the aesthetic
that I think will be most likely the
duffer brothers did say that the club
was looking for more members so it
really could represent a number of
things now before we get into the more
solid aspects of things that we know
rather than just the theories I want to
let you know we're giving away a free
copy of the Infinity Saga box set to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
be in with a chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts and the updates in
the comment section below the one is
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
March in the set will be shipped out
from the intro ever gets the prize so
best of luck to everyone who takes part
anyway according to the duffer brothers
the season will be influenced by five
specific films in the writers room they
stated that they've been looking over
the following the peanut butter solution
the Fisher King Bill & Ted's bogus
journey you've got mail and ordinary
people why this is interesting is
because the majority of these were
actually released during the 90s due to
the caste aging it is possible that the
season itself could be the first one set
during the decade you got mail could be
a reference to eleven and Mike's
relationship and there really is a ton
of things that we can pull from these
titles according to GamesRadar the show
also have eight episodes which is in
line with the previous seasons as for
the cast the main regulars including
Finn wolf odd Millie Bowie Brown David
Harbor and Winona Ryder aural returning
however deca Montgomery has not been
announced as being in the show so it is
unlikely that he will be back even in a
flashback Bret gentleman is also back as
Murray Borman and rumors are circulating
that Paul Reiser will be returning as
dr. Sam Owens Maya Hawke is to coming
back as Robin and the actor said that
she was excited to see where things
would evolve in the video store the show
is of course famous for featuring 80s
icons such as Winona Ryder Matthew
Modine Sean Astin and a lot more so who
knows who could pop up this time there
are rumors that Ethan Hawke aka my hoax
father could be popping up as a dad in
the show and there's a ton of things out
there that range from Molly Ringwald all
the way to Matthew Broderick all in all
there's heaps to look forward to
this video has given you a wealth of
things to speculate over whilst we wait
for the release of the show at some
point later this year obviously I'd
loved hear your thoughts on stranger
things for and what you think will
happen in the series comment below and
let me know and if you enjoy this video
then please give it a thumbs up and make
sure you check out our full breakdown of
the ending of HBO's The Outsider which
is gonna be linked at the end we go over
the finale of the season so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below those are
the best ways to keep up to date with
heavy spoilers so hopefully we see over
there very soon this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
you